that the motivation for me is just not
being average if I wanted to be on the
level of the peers that were around me I
had to do whatever it took you know to
get on that level and that was hard work
the doctor he didn't medically cleared
me to play so I had to sign a waiver to
release the the Eagles of any liability
[Applause]
the motivations watchit hot pan with
believe Nathan grab a snack and chew in
today's lessons from a man who went from
growing up in a tiny town in Alabama not
being heavily recruited in high school
and not seeing himself as having a
successful career as a football player
to becoming an NFL legend and one of the
best players of his era
he's Terrell Owens and here's my take on
his top 10 rules for success enjoy also
if you want to know what another great
athlete Hussein Bolt has to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence to link
to join is in the description below are
you going to race you have to go India
always confident
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have desire dedication and
discipline you didn't get recruited by
the Alabama's the Auburn's Els yep I was
a late bloomer yeah my body developed
late my skill set wasn't where it needed
to be to even capture the attention of
some of those schools of that caliber so
again you know when I look back on my
whole preferred professional career and
even you know scholastically you know
high school college without my desire
yeah coupled with my dedication and my
discipline those are my three DS desire
dedication of discipline without those
three I wouldn't be where I am today
rule number two seize your moment the
49ers selected Owens with the 89th pick
in the 1996 draft and he immediately
began to emulate one of his teammates
how was with the best receiver of all
time and I'm sitting right next to him
in my locker
I'm breathing the same air he's
breathing I'm sharing the same football
field I was in awe I was starstruck in
his third year Owens followed Jerry Rice
and the rest of his teammates into a
first-round playoff matchup with the
Green Bay Packers
[Applause]
yes
and the one point chris doumitt came
over get him out the game is blowing the
game for structure good third down
[Applause]
that I've ever seen Terrell Owens play
as
it came to me as it please don't give up
on me I promise you I got that I said
Terrell beep I said sir
you know like Terrell you're a great
player if you're open the balls coming
trailing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and I want to hit the ground I made sure
I had the ball secured and I rolled and
I thought about my grandmother
[Applause]
[Music]
I dropped so many passes but I come from
one account
Steve gave me a chance and I appreciate
everyone's a teammate I got in here yes
me saying no one's gonna give up on you
and then actually having it come out the
way it did that's one maybe when he
understood the impact he had that catch
probably established him as one of the
big-time players in the league because
just see his confidence go through the
roof
rule number three just do your best I
think a lot of people you know they said
they'll set these goals for themselves
and when they don't reach them then it's
discouraging and sometimes you need
somebody to push themselves sometimes
for me for me it was cell I was
self-motivated and sometimes other
people they need that little and they
need that little push that's the grind
of it all but you have to look at the
bigger picture you have to have belief
in yourself and you have to have faith
in yourself and faith is not really just
having or understanding that everything
will be okay but faith is is is
understanding that if things don't go
your way
or if it doesn't turn out the way you
want to it's still gonna be okay I think
it's gonna be okay no matter what or do
you think it's gonna be okay if you put
in the hard ass work yeah you got to put
in that work and got to understand that
it's gonna pay off
it may not pay off when you want it to
but that's the beauty of preparing
yourself and that's what I try to tell
my son and I try to you know really
emphasize don't worry about things that
you cannot control but the things that
you can't control that's what you have
to manifest because when the opportunity
is given to you and you don't step up to
the plate and you're not prepared who's
gonna be disappointed
not only your teammates or whoever
whoever gave you that opportunity is
gonna be disappointed but it's a big
letdown to yourself and now you're
starting to play mind games with
yourself did I do enough you know did I
put enough hard work into it but if you
know in your mind that you did
everything that you you you could do or
you did then nothing else nothing else
really matters rule number four outwork
everybody so the third leading receiver
in the history of the NFL isn't starting
a junior in high school until senior
north-north senior year either
are you kidding though you didn't start
as a senior in high school yes the Ennis
so you obviously Wow
like isn't that a lesson all you young
athletes that follow me hey just because
it's not where it needs to be right now
doesn't mean it can't get there and you
want you want to preneur it's that are
following me that may not be on the
varsity of business yet this is one of
the all-time greats in the history and
you're talking about by that time most
guys are being recruited they got eight
nine ten schools coming after us and
that's crazy so what did you do just
like every time you get an opportunity
just took advantage of it is that what
would happen I did my coach my head
coach at the time Steve Severus he
basically like it during the course of
the school year we have probably like a
30 to 45-minute period what they call it
enrichment period where we can either
study other you know work on other
subjects kind of to help get your grades
up things that nature I used that time
to go down to lift weights so he
basically went around to against they
send something around to all the
teachers that basically said yeah if a
player wants to go out you know if you
guys grant him let him get a pass to go
down to the weight room or what happens
so that's literally what I did I took
that those moments those 30 45 minutes
of enrichment period talk to the teacher
went down to the weight room and that's
where I started to do putting in extra
work just to kind of get myself bigger
fast and strong that always a theme
through the whole 15 years the NFL yeah
that was the start of it I was a kid
that was a kid that really that really
put in hard work I wasn't the most
athletic I wasn't the most sought after
wasn't the most highly recruited a lot
of coming out of high school going into
college not only did I work out in my
spare time when I was in high school
those 30 45 minutes here I didn't go
home during the summer
after my freshman sophomore year school
so I got the key from the strength and
conditioning coach I did the same thing
got the key to the weight here we go
did the same thing I would go and that's
how I got stronger because I was in
there by myself so I had to lift off by
myself yeah I had to be careful because
I was in there by myself nobody spotted
me so that's how I got stronger hmm so
these are some of the things that I did
unbeknownst to there you're all out
there in terms of how I how I made it
this is so good cuz you outwork
everybody it's also the things you do
when no one's watching like when you
played one of these everyone say aw his
physique is physique right now you know
where this comes from it doesn't happen
overnight it's awesome to hear rule
number five leverage negativity and what
I love about the things that have really
pissed you off or upset you is that
you've ended up leveraging it and you've
said you know look I've played through
pain I've played through people not
believing in me I played through hate
when I'm in an in that type of
environment you know having to sit sit
out a whole week and listen to all the
naysayers the negative things that that
were being said about me I didn't allow
that to deter who I was and what I could
do on the football field I understood
that if I went out we came in we got no
matter whatever the situation a scenario
was if I went out and I played poorly
knowing that all these commentator these
analysts were saying all these things
you know really really testing my
character really digging at my character
I knew that if I went out there not
played poorly that was gonna only
validate what they were saying about me
rule number six
just be yourself with Texas state the
David that was a question came up
whilst holding room and the answer rugs
cosmas 70s
this was God's 10 America's Team and
when door said most asked for touchdowns
God smiled on and the comment was if you
scored the mark go dead star and give
thanks to God
[Music]
look at the footage Tara was not being
disrespectful to the Dallas Cowboy that
wasn't doing her to tone anybody
I wasn't directing it at anybody I think
Emmitt Smith knew Cowboys typically
[Applause]
it's going to be a battle it's gonna be
a better okay we're at your house I did
the first time you did it okay we'll
stop me from doing it again
he said Stokes meet me back at the
original spot I'm right oh no you're not
gonna do this again
tackle
[Applause]
like that right before I had gone the
second time we were on the Gold Line
going up against George Teague and I
literally I Drive him to the back of the
his own and I literally pancaked him he
was so mad he couldn't get to me he
couldn't stop me so I came to the start
a second time you saw the first person
how to hit me was George Teague and that
was why I was pissed all right I chewed
him out in the locker room in front of
the team I said we will never win like
that and so I acted because I felt like
I should Steve Mariucci suspended Owens
for one week yeah I felt betrayed behind
it because I didn't feel the supportive
of the head coach that fractured our
relationship because he was pissed at me
forever he was the very best receiver in
the league for the next year and a half
he played angry but he played well Owens
made four straight Pro Bowls from 2000
to 2003 but his antics were garnering
more attention than his abilities
[Applause]
Owens became more boisterous on the
sidelines he also battled with
quarterback Jeff Garcia the tio persona
was growing yeah because I was raised by
my grandmother was to tell the truth you
know I didn't know anything about being
politically correct and most of the time
if we lost or whatever if I felt like I
didn't get involved enough in the game
then that's what I say it rule number
seven turn your struggles into strengths
I was bullied I was picked on as a
little kid as well hmm um I had
self-esteem issues I didn't like me in
dark skin I didn't like being skinny you
know so a lot of these things that I
would that I experienced as a young age
it motivated me as I as I grew up I hope
all you young guys out there or parents
who have young kids I hope you played
this part of the segment for him because
he turned that into fuel for himself
eventually writing rule number eight
finds your why when I played at
University of Tennessee Chattanooga
that's when I started getting a lot of
praise from a lot of the the defensive
coaches from opposing teams some of the
players just started getting recognized
throughout the conference of my play I
had a guy by the name of Derek Hall we
went to the same high school and so he
was heavily recruited that's how I got
to Chad knew because they were
recruiting him and so for me I just
basically took advantage of the
opportunities that were given to me did
you recognize that at the time like hey
I coming for him but I'm gonna crush it
I'm gonna put on a show I did not know
at all I was just there because they
offered me on scholarship my mom you
know she works you we came from a
low-income family so for me that was an
opportunity for me is to you know gain
an education so football was kind of
like you know just maybe secondary to me
I'm I'm in this environment with all my
teammates they were better than me I was
like man these guys are super fast or
super strong it's like how am I gonna
fit in so I realized at that time that I
had to get in a weight room in order to
really feel relevant I had to get on
their level and so those are some of the
things I think outside of everything
else that I kind of just prided myself
in is just really
putting forth the effort for me I didn't
really realize that I was gonna play
with you on the collegiate level I just
really had no idea what my future held
and that was just that the motivation
for me is just not being average
understanding that if I wanted to be on
the level of the peers that were around
me I had to do whatever it took you know
to get on that level and that was hard
work rule number nine don't let anything
stop you write something for the
Cardinal I mean you could hear the air
leave the stadium Bowens had a fractured
fibula and a high ankle sprain his
season appeared to be over well when I
talked to the doctors and I figured he
was done but I'm telling you now that
was never in his thinking for the
average person you know that's you know
maybe on some crutches or a boot or
something that's ten week process
I did everything under the Sun to get
myself better just having belief in
yourself when others don't have belief
in you and I saw myself playing
regardless Philadelphia was Superbowl
bound but one question still lingered on
everyone's mind the doctor he didn't
medically cleared me to play so I had to
sign a waiver to release the the Eagles
of any liability even during the week
when we went to Jacksonville he was
still gimpy I really I remember one
practice he went out he tried cutting on
and he kind of tweaked it he kind of had
to come out so I go
I don't see it
a football Super Bowl 39 about to begin
he's out running rodney harrison and i
remember looking to the deepest of
players on the sidelines saying we have
a chance to really win this game you
know that that was the big question
coming in and I think it's been answered
forty-five
would he be doing if he were healthy
just to have a guy like that out there
that's a huge booster
he's a damn did he did he break your leg
was he hurt he was out there clown
Bowens called nine passes for a hundred
and twenty-two yards
[Music]
that's just unfortunate we end up losing
by three points in effortful shorts
there will be no way
that's why the Philadelphia to this day
loves here because they do was hurt and
nobody thought he was gonna put he when
I take bought out man he brought to a
boil down and rule number ten the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
have fun this is what made tio a great
player he fought long and hard about
what he would do and then celebration
which meant he thought long and hard
about being in the end zone
gotta give TOS props wildly annoying
totally petulant button makes great ends
on celebrations
[Music]
grabbing the pom-poms and cheerleading
who doesn't laugh when you see that Plus
tear a little bit exploring some parts
of its personality we didn't know now
I've got a really special bonus cut from
Terrell Owens on how to add value that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life for business and feeling
bold leave your answers in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is your why number two what
struggle can you turn into your
strengths and number three where do you
need to outwork everyone okay sparingly
you know my my rookie year I played a
lot of special teams yes
catch a couple passes there yeah yeah
yeah I mean I think I had my I don't
know how many yards I had no I think I
had like four touchdowns my rookie year
but again I started kind of just
familiarizing myself with the playbook
go Steve Young job just a culture of
professional football in itself good and
so I go in my second year again going
into the offseason I'm preparing myself
yeah just to be a vital part a value to
the team and so we go into this my
second season first game we go down to
Tampa Jerry Rice I think he runs a
reverse or something and and Warren
steps I think just beat our defensive
man got him from behind
and he tears his ACL from that point on
I mean I get thrown into the fire here
we go and so that's where that
preparation you know that I and just me
familiarizing everything that I had done
my cooking year leading up to my second
year and I was preparing myself for this
moment
I loved it and if I wasn't prepared then
I wouldn't been able to add value to the
scene to the team you see I didn't say
success because I hadn't resided there
was no level of success at that point
Wow I was still trying to add value I
was trying to add value to to the Jerry
Rice's to the Steve Young to the JJ
Stokes to the organization to the team
itself Wow so I hadn't really
experienced any success at this point I
was still trying in that and that mode
of proving myself that I could play at
the professional level if you want to
see Tom Brady's top ten rules of success
check out the video there right next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there and it
was hard I remember taking a walk with
my dad and mom were on the block I have
a lot of fun I mean if we get to play
football for a living I mean what could
be any better than that